pavling était complètement raté montrer
des fleurs ou des nuages tout le monde
s'en moquait éperdument enfin c'était à
peu près nul alors je dis papa
laisse-moi faire c'est moi qui va être
le cameraman de la famille en tout cas
le biographe
alors vous êtes né en 1947 dit certains
forestiers en 1946 je ne sais pas c'est
46 47
46 46 donc alors vous avez gagné vous
êtes né en 46 donc à sennecynati dans
l'Ohio et la légende dit que vous êtes
né avec déjà au bout du bras une petite
caméra
au doigt de iti c'était une caméra
cinéaste caché peut-être que j'avais une
caméra sur moi dans ma personne dans ce
que je suis né j'en sais rien mais enfin
je fais des photos depuis que je suis
gamin en fait tout de suite vous avez eu
vous avez eu enfin je sais pas je sais
pas c'est une légende mais que des vous
avez vous êtes emparé la caméra de votre
père il savait pas tourner vous vous lui
ai montré déjà comment vous êtes devenu
une sorte de d'accro de de cet
instrument
c'est vrai
des caméras des caméras Kodak j'ai pu
filmer des histoires et raconter mais
également des appareils photos mais mon
père effectivement
et puis il filmait nos vacances on
partait en vacances tout le temps et
alors je lui ai pris effectivement sa
caméra qu'ils étaient oui ils savaient
pas tenir la caméra ça tremblait tout le
temps il arrivait pas rester en place il
y avait un plan fixe pendant une seconde
ou deux et puis après il passait
ailleurs le travelling était
complètement raté montrer des fleurs ou
des nuages tout le monde s'en moquait et
perduement enfin c'était à peu près nul
alors je dis papa laisse-moi faire c'est
moi qui va être le cameraman de la
famille en tout cas le biographe de la
famille je sais pas c'était le film
grade de la famille enfin toujours
est-il que j'ai pris la caméra en main
puis alors ce que j'ai fait
au lieu de simplement filmer nos
vacances j'ai en effet des histoires je
les ai dramatiser je voulais pas
accepter la réalité au premier degré
j'ai peut-être exagéré par exemple
lorsqu'il y avait un feu de camp ou on
allait à la pester une grosse aventure
j'en faisais des grosses affaires mais
l'autre aromatiques et c'était ma
première expérience mais il paraît que
vous fassiez déjà payer l'entrée quand
vous montriez vos films vous demandiez
25 ça vaut petit camarades
plus tard après après les les vacances
dans GT scout ensuite et je voulais
avoir la médaille du photographier pour
ça il fallait raconter une histoire avec
des photos alors j'ai demandé au chef
des scouts si je pouvais raconter une
histoire filmée avec la caméra de mon
papa et comme ça je pouvais avoir ma
médaille alors ça s'appelait gunsmork
le premier film que j'ai fait avec une
bobine de 3 minutes 10 mm et c'était un
western en fait que j'ai filmé dans dans
batelain de l'Arizona ou je vivais à
l'époque beaucoup de films d'ailleurs il
y avait été tournés et bien ce film que
j'ai présenté au scout m'a valu cette
médaille mais ça m'a également lancé
dans le cinéma parce que j'étais
complètement épris de la caméra pouvoir
filmer des scènes les montées
monter des dialogues pour moi c'est
fantastique mais c'est par réaction
contre l'autorité de vos parents qui
vous ne voulez pas que vous alliez au
cinéma qui vous détournaient de cet art
peut-être un peu maléfique que vous
aviez en vous cette rage de tourner des
films on dit que vous avez même tourné
16 ou 17 films pendant votre pendant
votre scolarité
effectivement mes parents ne voulaient
pas que j'aille au cinéma parce qu'ils
estimaient que ils ne maîtrisait pas le
cinéma ils avaient peur que la violence
qu'on y voyait pouvait être dans
dangereux c'est à dire que moi j'étais
très impressionnable quand j'étais gamin
si je voyais un serpent à l'écran j'ai
été terrifié alors il voulait pas que
que j'aille au cinéma ils m'ont emmené
voir quelques films par exemple les
comédies musicales avec Fred Astaire ça
d'accord mais par exemple le premier
signe que j'ai vu c'était le film de
Cécile B2000
j'étais très jeune à l'époque mais enfin
à part cette époque je jouais
au train électrique j'organisais des
accidents ferroviaires avec des traits
miniatures alors mon père m'a dit si tu
crées un autre accident comme ça je te
confie ce que tes trains alors je dis il
faut que il faut que je fasse des
accidents pour mes pour mes films alors
ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai filmé
avec ma caméra le dernier accident alors
un train aller de gauche à droite et
puis je savais intuitivement que pour
que ça marche il fallait que je reste de
l'autre côté de la ligne en filmant le
même train mais dans l'autre sens alors
j'ai mis la caméra entre les deux
sur la même voix pour organiser pour
organiser l'accident alors je n'ai pas
fait d'autres accidents mais je me suis
filmé je me suis représenté cette
accident d'état de foi mais l'une des
choses les plus étonnantes c'est quand
même quand vous étiez très jeune vous
êtes allé au studio Universal vous êtes
rentrés dans le studio et voilà notre
entrée vous êtes restés pendant deux ans
dans le studio on vous faisant passer
pour quelqu'un qui travaillait et c'est
comme ça que vous avez réellement appris
votre métier n'est-ce pas
d'abord je suis allé chez la Warner mais
en fait effectivement pendant deux ans
je me suis fait passer pour un employé
de la Universal et j'étais avec des
cousins en Californie effectivement
c'est chez les Universal et la légende
dit est-ce que c'est une légende de la
vérité que vous vous êtes vous-même mis
à la porte du studio Universal parce que
vous n'y aviez rien à faire au bout de
deux ans au bout de deux ans
je ne me suis pas mise à la porte mais
enfin ce qui s'est passé c'est que
j'avais passé deux étés donc à
l'Universal et puis je me suis décidé
qu'il fallait passer plus de temps il
fallait que je j'évite le service
militaire j'étais à deux doigts d'être
engagés au Vietnam alors je me suis
intéressé à mes notes scolaires j'avais
de tellement mon mauvaises notes à
l'université parce que je passais tout
mon temps au studio que l'université
studio aurait pu
m'embarquer au service militaire alors
il fallait que je me concentre sur mon
activité universitaire pour ne pas être
engagé alors c'est grâce à la télévision
vous avez fait vos débuts de cinéaste
les Français peut-être pas que vous avez
même tourné un Columbo et puis et
d'autres films de télévision et on va
avoir un que vous avez tourné et vous
n'aviez que 20 ans il s'intitulait night
Gallery avec une star mais alors un
monstre sacré du cinéma et je répète
vous n'aviez que 20 ans qui s'appelle
John Crawford et elle elle avait 65 ans
et elle avait 65 ans et vous avez été
impressionné vous avez dû être
terrifié terrifié ah ouais effectivement
j'étais terrifié intimidé très
impressionné et puis je dois lui dire et
je m'en souviens bien elle a été très
gentille avec moi et en fait elle a eu
pitié il paraît que vous l'avez séduit
en lui amenant une rose tous les matins
et une bouteille de Pepsi Cola car elle
était la présidente de la peps
psychologue compagnie oui c'est vrai
mais je mettais la rose de la bouteille
vide de Pepsi
j'étais assez balicieux à l'époque quand
même
[Musique]